Women are only fertile for about
six days of their cycle.
And when they're able to identify these days,
they can avoid pregnancy naturally.
And every time I talk about this,
I get so much backlash from the internet.
So let's talk about the science
as I eat my frozen grapes.
But let me make something clear.
This is not the rhythm method
that you're predicting when you may be fertile
and just praying.
This is a science backed method
that tracks the signs that your body gives you
in response to fluctuating hormones.
So let me show you
how your fertility and menstrual cycle actually works.
This image represents the menstrual cycle.
Starts the first day of your period,
goes to the first day of your next period.
And up here is a reflection of the hormonal activity
throughout the cycle
and what that subsequently looks like
when you're looking at the egg follicle,
which is the sack that houses the egg in the ovaries.
And a forewarning you,
this might have to be two parts
cause there's a little bit of information here.
So you are only actually fertile
in the five days leading up to ovulation,
where sperm can survive within the body
with estrogenic mucus present,
as well as the 12 to 24 hours after ovulation.
So once the egg has been released,
that the egg is actually viable,
after those 24 hours,
it disintegrates
and you're no longer fertile.
Now as this egg follicle is Growing
it is producing estrogen,
and estrogen has to hit a sufficient level
in order to trigger the release of lutinizing hormone,
which is the hormone that is actually going to
rupture the egg follicle and release the egg.
I'm out of time
and out of grapes,
so go to part 2,
which is already up.